optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so now I'm supposed to
know I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton so this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
first books is now the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self-employed professionals and used
by more than 10 million people
you can send invoices track your time
and get paid fast which basically
describes the core needs of most
entrepreneurs and freelancers the
product was recently relaunched and
rebuilt from the ground up focusing on
simplicity and speed it's an awesome
service and many of you recommended it
to me which is how they came to be a
sponsor now I can't cover all of the
many many features but for example you
can take pictures of receipts on your
phone using freshbooks iOS mobile app or
connect your bank account or credit card
to fresh books and watch your expenses
automatically import into your account
every day and if you have any questions
whatsoever a real live person answers in
less than three rings to help you with
all of your needs so to claim your 30
day unrestricted free trial that means
no credit card needed and see how the
all-new fresh books can change your
freelancing game go to FreshBooks
dot-com forward slash Tim and enter Tim
T I am in me how did you hear about us
section that is fresh ebooks.com forward
slash Tim and then put Tim T I am in the
how did you hear about us section
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice that
become incredibly popular among my
friends in Silicon Valley and across the
country because they provide the same
high end financial advice that the best
private wealth managers delivered to the
ultra wealthy but for any account size
and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the power is in
the software wealthfront now manages
more than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront
is powered by innovative technology
making it the most tax efficient
low-cost
hassle-free way to invest they don't a
polluted sales teams or retail locations
so they can deliver all of this
sophisticated financial advice and these
services at a fraction of the cost of a
traditional financial advisor so the
very least go-to wealthfront come
forward / Tim and take their free risk
assessment survey it only takes a couple
of minutes and wealthfront will
recommend a personalized portfolio of
investments in other words they'll tell
you exactly where they would put your
money so even if you don't use their
service you have a huge leg up and you
have additional information for making
good decisions they use investment
theory to automate good financial
behavior and decisions that people
typically don't make but should so go to
wealthfront com4 / Tim to get your first
15k managed for free or just to get more
details check it out wealth front comm
forward / Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types whether they are
from the worlds of business sports
entertainment military or otherwise in
this episode we have Ricardo Semler
who was by popular request and has
certainly had a large impact on me he
came up not too long ago in the very
very popular podcast episode with DHH
David Hannah Mayer Hanson who is of the
37signals Basecamp and Ruby on Rails
Fame who also credits Ricarda with
having a huge impact on him so who is
Ricardo who I always want to call he
cardinal because he is originally from
Brazil he is the former CEO of Semco a
Brazilian company best known perhaps for
its radical form of industrial democracy
and corporate re-engineering and all
that will make more sense as we get into
the conversation we really focus on
entrepreneurship even though there's so
much more to talk about including
education and what he's done with his
lumia our schools but going back to
Semco under his ownership or during his
leadership certainly both revenue grew
from four million dollars u.s. in 1982
to 212 million u.s. dollars so in 2013
and his innovative business management
policies which are very controversial
attracted very widespread interest all
over the world he's tossed mit he's done
many many other things and most recently
he has started a podcast which he's
checkout called lead wise and you can
find that at podcast dot dot CEO on
Twitter you can find them at Ricardo
Semler or at let's lead wise if you want
to be hot at podcast specific so you can
check out both of those Facebook let's
lead wise and then LinkedIn Ricardo
Semler and I should also provide some
context for two very similar sounding
book titles so he wrote the seven-day
weekend in 2003 which had a big impact
on me the 4-hour workweek I'm not sure
how happy is about how I was seemingly
related those titles are but came about
so those people who don't know the story
from the original title of the book
which was drug dealing for fun and
profit which was the tongue-in-cheek
name of the guest lecture I gave at
Princeton
high tech entrepreneurship ultimately
for at least 10 years something is
around 2003 to 2013 or so and when the
book was sold to crown within Random
House at the time there were a few
retailers I want to say might have been
Walmart who really didn't like drug
dealing for fun and profit so I quickly
sketched out as did they I'd say a dozen
or so prospective titles and one of the
ideas was the to our work week because
that's how long it took me to manage my
company at the time but that seemed too
unrealistic so I was like alright we'll
go up to four hours a week and then I
tested that along with the other titles
in Google Adwords and for let's just
call it $200 a week later
since Google mixes and matches the the
ad headlines which were the titles and
the ad text which were my sub titles I
knew which combination at the highest
click-through rate and that is how we
ended up at the 4-hour workweek but no
matter I will put a shot of a photograph
of my self-made index at the beginning
of the seven-day weekend which is a
great book and I recommend people check
out and this conversation ranges very
very widely and I hope you enjoy it as
much as I did so without further adieu
please enjoy my conversation with
Ricardo Semler Carlo welcome to the show
thank you thank you I'm so happy to have
you on the phone and on the show because
I have been a fan for so long and I in
fact have this copy of one of your books
the seven-day weekend
which has travelled with me for at least
10 years now I bought it when I first
came out and I was looking at the index
that I made for myself in the very
beginning which I'll have to take a
photograph of and send to you so first
of all as it came up in my conversation
with with DHH on the podcast as want to
thank you for sharing your experiences
wonderful I you know I'm obviously I
have a copy here so work week or similar
name and Alex's photograph of that
believe that you've actually carried it
around but it's great to catch up kind
of you
very thoughtful about all these really
deep issues of how to live how to work
and how do you put putting them into
things which is my concern as well so I
think we'll we'll want to jump into that
and also talked quite a lot about
education a lot of my audience has many
many questions about learning and
education so we will certainly get to
that but for those people who don't have
a lot of background a lot of context
could you give us perhaps just a
snapshot of where you grew up
and your childhood just as a starting
point and then we can depart from there
to many different places but that would
be very helpful place to start sure and
you know I was thinking about it the
other day when I've been trying to work
with some guys in the UN and elsewhere
about putting education platforms into
refugee camps in it and it it kind of
explains my background as well my my
parents were both Austrian refugees and
my mother was a refugee in all respects
of the world and since the Sheep ran
away from Vienna to Shanghai spent 11
years in Shanghai but then was kicked
out of Shanghai by a multi-ton in 1949
and then actually spent 18 months in a
tent in a refugee camp in the South of
France and she was one of these
displaced persons who had no passport
whatsoever and so it's it's very
interesting how we see different
variations of the word refugee but the
fact is that she then became an
immigrant in in Brazil which the only
place that accepted her and and so much
later where I was born and she had she
lost seven pregnancies and stillborn etc
and so she always regarded me as
somewhat of a miracle and and Freud
always says that if your mother believes
in you absolutely that you can do
anything then you can do anything and
that's the only thing it takes and so
they're interesting because I grew up in
a household it was already well-to-do
and we had everything and
when I got to about 1213 I got involved
with rock bands and then I I spent a lot
of time as a roadie and then as and
playing I was never terribly good but
enough to kid all the way and enough to
trickly tell my friends into thinking I
was very good and going on stage here
and there which I think probably the
most important part of it you know and
so so wide by the time I was 17 or 18 I
was I was very much in that mode but my
father then who was 15 years older than
me and I was very interesting also
because I kept looking at years Overman
span is almost my grandfather and that's
that I could never do that myself and so
forth and so promptly I had a son now
when I was 50 so um
he's now assessed so I'm like so so this
stuff comes back to bite you in the ass
but this the fact is that then I was 17
he wanted me to you know he kept taking
me to the planted saying someday all
this will be yours because a
manufacturing plant which pumps and very
heavy equipment he's very engineering
oriented there were about a hundred
people there and the students have been
there for a long time and doing
relatively well but then it started
deteriorating so that by the time I was
19 or 20 the whole business the whole
industry for that was it was in very bad
shape at that point I had decided to do
law school because I didn't want to do I
thought business school in general was
very restricted and very much turned to
the past and so first I wanted more and
more humanistic background I did that
and then that joined the company and
when I joined the company kind of
following his wishes while I was still
doing law school I realized that we had
a big big difference in the way we saw
the world or how we would run things it
was very traditional and Aquarion
three-piece suit I was wearing a
three-piece suit with a watch in my
pocket she's pretty in blue and then why
was your watch in your pocket because
this was my grandfather's watch and my
father what went in his pocket with a
little gold chain and pulled it out
every so I think you know I was ready to
smoking pipes you know this is the world
that was staring in the face was very
very curious but and of course this was
all colliding with the rock guitarist
and bassist which I thought I was I had
hair down to the middle my back until
here before you know so this was all
very strange and it was a very strange
world and I saw people getting having to
come to to the company and be surged on
their way out and have exact times if
there were five minutes late and docking
pay and as soon as in straw Denari worth
compared to what I'd seemed up to then
let's say in the world of rock and so
when I started looking all that at a
certain point I told him I said Nicholas
were incompatible here this is what I
would do here is so different and
probably you're saying it would never
work so let me go do something else
and for a while he just kind of took the
bluff and said sure go see what else you
can do
and I found at that point that the
business world was more interesting that
I thought and that I could do something
with it and I went out and started
looking for opportunities to do
something on my own and that was not a
world thirty-five forty years it was not
a world of startups or anything sort so
if you wanted to start a business this
is all very hardworking oriented so I
went out and I talked to people who were
in the consulting business said you know
I want to buy a company but I don't
actually have anybody to base right and
if I were when it paper would be my dad
buddy of course that makes no sense
whatsoever and then I finally found a
consultant at Price Waterhouse of all
places who helped me said no we have to
do the following we'll look for
companies that are broke that have no
money whatsoever they have big debt if
you're not scared of taking on that and
you can buy these companies for a dollar
I said the dollar I have let's go do
that and so we looked at dozens and
dozens of companies finally got to one
which was a ladder company made metal
and wooden ladders
and and I got to the point of signing
those 200 page contract of sitting at
the lawyer's office to sign the purchase
of this company which was really very
high negative worth of questions ahead
big dad how's our problems but the guy
wanted to get rid of it and I said give
it to me and suddenly my father burst
into me law office and said what does it
cost to pay the fine took to undo this
deal that's another set of fans I
remember $200,000 which seemed like an
enormous amount of time and so he he
paid it and we we paid the fine and
didn't sign the agreement and then I
started with a company so it's a very
interesting beginning now this this I
think and please correct me if I'm wrong
with probably chronologically is close
to something I want to ask you about
that a lot of my listeners wanted to ask
you about and that was when you took the
reins as CEO maybe you could describe
the circumstances but the firing of 60%
of top managers is as one of the first
decisions and I don't know if that is as
straightforward as it might seem but the
question that came up from a lot of my
listeners was how did you make that
decision and I would just love to hear
the circumstances surrounding it and
these thought processes that went into
your first decisions when that
transition took place yeah and it's it's
interesting I mean what what I told you
we will all now connect to that of
course but and then and it's interesting
in the thought process from the saying
oh your your your listeners want to know
this one or that and I just I just
started them it's just we have our guys
been sitting a little podcast and and
with color leading wisely and meeting
wisely is all about this issue you know
how do you make some decisions like that
one firing most of the people and how do
you know that it's folly or
wisdom when you start you know and so I
gotten to that point where it was either
him or me in the sense of there were two
ways of trying to read this and at that
point the business wasn't doing very
well which gave me an opportunity but as
I looked out at these people maybe you
know we had a hundred people so maybe
twenty of them a little bit more were
either managers supervisor or somebody
we're meeting capacity and I looked at
these people and I'd already had a
little bit experience with trying to
change things and people were always
explained to me why it can't be done so
they would listen very patiently and
then they would say yeah okay but here I
knew you know you're 19 just a private
at this and the time because we've been
in this business for so long and there's
this if there's an event and I realized
that in the amount of time it would take
me to turn these people around and to
deal with the unconscious sabotage that
everyone who is in place applies or
wails you know anyone who is coming into
something is always new and hasty and
doesn't really understand you and so it
takes a heck of time in the business at
that point it's not doing well enough to
withstand a long cycle and then I read
the amount of sabotage that I'd have and
the amount of interactions the
permutations of firing three people then
create an alert and panic and the other
six people who talk to the other five
behind our backs and so far that seemed
like we didn't have the time for that
and it seemed obvious that these people
were terribly in place and completely
calcified with all these there's been
there so I took a rash decision which
may be only a 19 or 20 year old we do
probably would never comes I don't think
I have encouraged to do that today again
but I looked out there and I said we we
just had to pull the band-aid off this
thing so that I could start the next day
and so on one protest and I just called
people in what I'd never hire them but
much less tired anyway and then I fired
out at all 16 17 manager
director than that included the CEO the
CFO or anybody who mattered and and
these people went home Friday and didn't
return on Monday and we spent the whole
weekend going into these people's filing
cabinets this was all paper and going to
the sauna cabinet and trying to figure
out what the hell is going on in this
company and we would look at it and we'd
see a customer name would say I wonder
who this customer is that we had no idea
and it was really it was really quite a
quite a roller coaster ride but I think
in the end it made us change direction
of course very quickly so that 60 days
the end we were completely different
company and then it was possible to
throw out the whole rule book from from
nothing and say wait a sec what what
part of this do we really need and what
part of it has just been here forever
and doing that slowly I think would have
killed me and the other guys as well did
you have many conversations before
making that decision was it was it scary
for you to do that I guess
it just seems like such a you said rash
but also I mean courageous in some
respects decision for someone at that
age in that position did you have any
conversations inside your head or with
other people that allowed you to take
that that lead to make that decision I'm
just wondering what strategy led up to
it yeah I'm imagining that there must
have been and I can think basically than
one or two people who from the beginning
I felt would be on the right side and we
made that test it was slightly but I
already knew as well that I couldn't
embossed the system or the wrong people
and I didn't know enough people I
remember talking to my dad a few days
before because he was about to go on a
trip to Europe and I said you know I
have to do a few things here and it
might involve some innings an ionizer
and as I do everything while I'm gone
and as soon as you have to get traveling
traveled on Thursday I call everybody
and on Friday so but I think it's not
gonna run inside my head in the sense
that geez you know
as I try to do this the old-fashioned
way or the SoulCycle this is going to be
10 times it's hard but also the chance
that I actually get to the end of this
is smaller and I felt in their respects
that on top of it being rush I felt I
really had no option there was no time
and we needed to do this very quickly
now of course that gave me an
opportunity to have a start up let's say
on Monday from a business that was
already 30 years old on Friday mm-hmm
and you I want to flash forward a little
bit and I'm sure we'll fill in the some
of the gaps and there will be stories
that will come back but can you please
describe the I would love to know the
actual meaning of the title V Rondo
opprobrium ASA and which is as I
understand it later became maverick but
clearly in I don't speak Portuguese but
seems to means something very different
than maverick could you describe how
that book came to be and as I understand
it became the best-selling non-fiction
book in the history of Brazil which is
saying something I mean there are a lot
of books have spent some time in Brazil
it's it that that's a non-trivial a
college minh so what does botando
program is I mean it literally means
turning your own tables but it's
basically turning the tables with you're
stuck in the middle there to make it
more selfish no but it was really about
in and brilliant Portuguese it makes a
little bit more sense but it is in the
same in the same vein which is say
turning everything upside down and so
forth which was this whole process of
starting from scratch and changing the
rules and parity and it was really just
at because let's say from to maybe the
five six years after this mass firing
let's say in which we started redoing
things we started asking questions and I
don't know it seems a very simple
process but actually when you do it you
realize the potential which was the
whole process of asking
three wise in a row that was the only
thing we were doing I said since we're
starting this again tell me again why do
we search people on the way out by to
all people have to arrive at the same
time etc and when you ask three wives in
a row the first white people have a very
good answer for they've been thinking
about this for a long time living this
robotic more than they're practicing it
along time yeah and some people say why
do people have to be here at the same
time and they'll look at and say oh poor
kid
look little done spun explain to you if
the guy comes here the guy next time on
the assembly line is not here yes and
line does not move and that's the first
the first set of wife and it just
becomes more sophisticated but they did
the same thing to me at Law School the
Harvard Business School everywhere I
heard the same condescending response to
all and explains two so the first why is
the easy one and I always say that you
know I have five kids and it's mom's 27
and I always say that you know when you
have the three wives and you ask them
they ask you something anything they
said that why is this this way and the
first question the first why did he do
the answer and then they'll say but why
that and then you start getting into a
little trouble you solo you know really
from there by the third way you're wrong
one option which is to buy them in ice
cream and this is this is what happened
to be there so I'd say why do we are so
common right I'm at the same time or we
say why would we all dress the same way
while wearing suits of type oh you know
so that will look more like each other
okay great why do we want to look more
like each other no because this is the
same with almost anything you ask of
business rules there was a reason
sometimes somebody that was concerned
something but it wasn't really essential
to what you're trying to do and so we
would say if we can't answer the three
wise about anything or about a rule
let's just throw it out and let's see
what's left and we're left with
absolutely nothing crow anything of
really important and and so we started
organizing ourselves around this new way
of if you can't
justify it absolutely let's try to do it
without and that went for organization
charts and boxes and titles and we were
asking things like I can't you just set
your own title choose any title you want
put it on a business card and if the guy
who wants to is going to buy from you
and you put there rather write VP
Regional Sales Manager instead of
trainee I don't care as long as he buys
from you and you trust you and deliver
the product and off we go
and so we started doing this with
everything and so we threw out their
decisions are we threw out job titles we
said very quickly start asking question
why doesn't everyone know what everyone
else makes here why can't people set
their own salaries and nothing resisted
three wise in a row and but to make a
long story short suddenly this the
company started very well and then
instead of hundred people here two
hundred and then five hundred and a
thousand and two thousand and at a point
we said people start a on your you've
got a right in pull you know they've
gotta tell this story to book and I
picked out a couple organized but at a
certain point in time I started passing
unreadable so I started on a Friday and
I had on the other Sunday so I spent
nine days writing and and that was it
and it's interesting because I
considered that book so belonging to two
you know the thin air and not to myself
that I never corrected any grammatical
mistakes and and it came to me from data
publishers many times as you sure you
don't want to correct that you this is
silly what you wrote here and there's
stuff that I'm not at all proud of
anymore of course and there's a lot of
mistakes and I said million can't touch
it considered ISM belong twenty buddy
and so what happened was I sent it out I
finished it in in me you Inc and it was
nine hundred pages of pen and ink and I
I took it I had I had someone typed it
and then I send it out to the eight big
auto shows in Brazil and the eight
rejected and an infinitive very long
either
the
rejected and they said you know nobody
wants to hear anything from Brazilian
businessmen they're buying the Iacocca
and that kilo meter and all these guys
and they're home but we must adhere
Ferguson businessman and then one of the
guys talked to me said you know what we
could do we could get this out as a
year-end gift from the company wouldn't
that be nice
three hundred copies or something and I
said yeah my ego is not small enough for
that I can't do that and then I I found
a publisher who was the ninth and I said
not possible you've got to punish this
this for me in a small version you can't
you can't lose all that much money so
far so finally the guy said sure I'll
I'll do it and we had a very interesting
discussion about royalties because he
said you know what you get is 10% words
and so on that sounds like I said what
if it sells more than five thousand
copies and so he laughed and it's not
hola it's ok 11% anyway we had this
whole this whole table because I kept
baskets but what about 50,000 he's
almost fall off the table laughing is
like that 15 but anyway so I got 20%
zeroes out about a million really sailed
and but what happened was I I really
never thought of course that I knew what
I was doing and I know this book was
very necessary knows nothing sort but I
just wanted at least to get it out there
but it apparently was a bit like a
surfboard you know that you're sitting
there and suddenly the big wave comes to
waste I didn't make you know there
people were apparently ready to think
about a different way of doing things
and so they took they took the book
forward and it is nothing happened at
all because people the book out there
was no publicity there was nothing in
about week later somebody follows and
somebody wrote a review and then it's
been 200 weeks on the vessel is of which
150 weeks and number one it was very
simple it's just went mouth to mouth and
apparently it hit it had
a moment a nerve a time in which it went
off on its own but so that's a long
waited response to it's called turning
the tables because of this whole turning
things upside down and finding out that
it works just as well in our case a lot
better I have a couple while I'll have a
million follow-up questions but I have a
few that are related to have talked
about so far so the first is and this
might seem super specific but what is
what is the right way to fire someone or
how how would you go about firing
someone now or to those entrepreneurs
listening so of course you had your
approach when you first came into the
company but how is that changed or
evolved over time what is what is the
right way to fire someone if you need to
let someone go you know that sometimes
my my wife says that you know it's it's
so nice being fired by you that I keep
thinking this was a very positive thing
to do and I see all these people getting
up here after you say I really have to
start this person then they get up and
they're smiling they're patting you on
the back is that look how are you doing
with this firing process but the fact is
this that one when when you get close to
some people are surprised but most
people have an inkling already that
things are not doing well I have this
this if someone's working close to me
and that's the only situation of course
where there's firing situation but
persons working close to me and it's not
it's not going place it's early on I do
very little of that let's do this again
let's do another another chance another
way another cycle it's that are so it's
highly highly intuitive and so to me if
it doesn't feel right it's not good for
the person or for me to continue and so
I'll sit the person down and say this
isn't working and and from many respects
the personal side and realize the
writing things from that wait a second
is an app and it's all about being very
very exceedingly frank and saying you
know most of the time it's a situation
which a so you can definitely count on
good references let me see if I can help
you let's think about it
where
you can go from here inside of that and
mostly I think that's the bit of white
people in the induction so bad about it
is because I look forward a bit a few
months or a few years and I say you're
going to be stuck here
I want this from you you're not you're
obviously this isn't fitting your
profile entirely and you're going to
keep at it keep at it at it but slowly
we're going to start the abrasion will
set in you know and I'll be more
ill-humour about this or you'll find
that getting up on Monday morning coming
to do this isn't as fun as it used to be
let's cut all this edit at the root and
gives you a real chance of finding
something that makes you a lot happier
and normally I'll say the distances near
makes may seem like something you do
well but let me tell you this this
doesn't work but this that you're good
at you should be able to find a way to
do that and none of it ends relatively
well because it is so based on on
transparency you know definitely and
when you subject these conventions to
the three wise and everything falls
apart or just isn't justifiable so now
you're effectively dealing with a blank
canvas how do you choose what to do
first or if somebody does this in a
company is there particular order you
might suggest that they tackle things in
if if they're just left with all these
rules from all the way from say
marketing to finance to hiring to fill
in the blank have have fallen by the
wayside because they can't be justified
where do you start because I could see a
lot of people feeling scattered or
becoming scattered how do you choose or
how did you choose what to do first
second third you know when you when you
think Tim about what you write about and
what inspires you and how you go into
the issue of a work week or a chef or a
workout or how to live life wisely
you're basically concentrated on process
the process by which you do all of this
is the one that makes sense so I would
definitely start by the process
that takes us out of bed you know that
makes you get up in and go somewhere to
do something that that process is the
first one that needs to be changed so
how often do you want to work how many
hours do you want to work who you want
to work with in what place you want to
work that is the one that to me would be
the number-one issue because if you have
people in your company organization
wherever you are that are doing this
because you told them to or somebody
told them to it's always been done that
way or people aren't stopping to think
about why the heck should I take a
subway and a bus and go to a place
downtown and so forth this is the stuff
that is undermining your whole
opportunity to have the right process so
I would always start with do you is this
really what you want to do oh yeah I
love doing okay but you love doing it at
this time of the day no not really
actually if I could take my kids school
personal right this is the stuff that I
would take off you know what is it
what's the stuff that you're doing or
how you're doing it which somebody asked
for or somebody thought was going to be
smart or was a good idea four years ago
yeah this is a day and I'm starting
interrupting this is something you would
ask of every employee yeah and and we
did of course and so we ended up of
course with people who didn't want to
come at the same time who didn't want to
work there anymore we went from one one
building which was when we started
asking this question we had one central
building and everybody came to us and
this was the obvious solution within
maybe a year year and a half we had 14
different places around town and so we
would say go to the places nearest your
house or nearest the customer you want
to visit or don't go anywhere but don't
even tell us because we don't want to
have any one who keeps tabs on you
because your process of how you want to
do this is the most important thing and
let's negotiate you and us let's
contract for something you're going to
do are you going to sell 66 widgets a
week oh great so if you sell 56 widgets
on Wednesday please go to the beach on
Thursday and Friday do not show up in
some more widgets because you're going
to create an enormous problem for and
and manufacturing and in sumer have to
go up by another company on another day
don't do this before we start it through
sell your 656 with where you're going to
do it from how you did it that is none
of our concern don't tell us just tell
the statistics which is there will
always be fine and this is true for
everything else is true for account is
true for marketing and so forth and so
the process of how you're going to do
this is necessarily yours and we don't
want to be in the way so here are 14
different places you can go to if you
want you can stay in bed we don't care
don't tell us how many hours you work or
how hard it was so the widgets because
we don't have any place to put that
information that was the whole focus on
pressed and when you're asking why not a
B and C right when you're when you're
testing these assumptions are there any
particular notable failures that come to
mind with tests that you performed oh
yeah
and and I can I can think of a few and
I'll tell you true but the main thing is
that the enormous amount of mistakes
that one makes in organizations with
your wife with your kids at the church
in a group Italian and so forth it's so
humungous that you have to consider a
bit you know the Babe Ruth permutation
that if you just hit more home runs than
you missed about the key thing how many
times it they will miss the ball and
here we have very little in general
little patience for these mistakes and
and my thing is really to brush aside
the mistake that's great we that was
wrong with let's try this again now if
we're wrong again and again and guinness
that's really no problem we just have to
be batting in the right direction so
there's a lot of things that we started
that we thought was was really smart you
know weeks period all of this out and
for example we with it with the whole
search thing that was a very big issue
because we had we had all these
electronic components we had all kinds
of stuff which people said crazy people
take this in their purses and in their
hair and so fine
and and we said it doesn't matter you
mean searching employees on the way out
sorry Sir John and I'm going back here
35 years shores and in Brazil but this
is this was a big issue because everyone
kept checking stocks and there's always
something missing from inventory and
this was all very expensive stuff which
was easy to take we worked you know and
the motors were all copper wires and
there was silver this and then there was
components and so forth and and I was
saying you know the process here is that
I cannot work with people that I
interact with that we try to do things
together with I have empathy with and
then I search on their way out to find
out whether they're stealing from me
that this just not possible it can't be
done and so for some time that didn't
work at all because slowly are in we had
a lot of inventory problems and the
amount of losses that we had in the
months following was obviously people
look at this at see here Sooey I you
know it's getting worse and my reaction
is that at that point was do we do we
keep this inventory
safe and locked up and people have to
requisition it yes yes ok well let's
give up that process as well and just
leave the store is completely open the
inventory anybody can take anything and
then for the first time we had a
decrease until the problem went away
because because the whole process was if
we're showing you here and there that we
don't trust you and sign this and lock
this and and so forth and then we're
just making sure you don't steal so it's
a crazy situation it's always a very
small minority people and as we put the
process in place people started saying
through a form where they would it would
come together at a median decide who
they needed in their air for the next
six months and slowly the system
expelled the people who were just
stealing and I don't know what happened
over the years you're saying these 35
years of people stolen more or less it's
better if we don't measure we have no
idea we've never had any idea but it's
never become an issue big enough to
about since you know and so what I meant
to say was that we make a lot we made a
lot of mistakes in every one of these
processes when we started telling people
in the center line that they could time
could come anytime they wanted they
could leave their kids at school they
could stay longer in bed of course for a
time the sames line
suffered and we didn't deliver some
products and people were putting their
hairs out but then a few weeks later
suddenly these people realize and they'd
say well wait a second if you're not
here this is something that is going to
move so what time you think you're
getting here tomorrow and a whole new
schedule started coming into place so I
think ultimately if the process decision
is to trust people to believe in people
as people the issues go away with time
and they just look like the stakes in
the short-term so I think this is
actually a good place to perhaps tie
this to folks who are listening you have
say smaller companies so let's just say
they have you er than 10 employees a lot
of people listening to this are
entrepreneurs they might be solopreneurs
who are doing their first hiring or
people with small groups small teams
what are some experiments or questions
or any type of assumption busting that
you might suggest they test for
themselves
is there any are there any good starting
points for people who have processes in
place but they're small teams relatively
flexible but very very resource
constrained where might they start in
terms of testing I think that I'm doing
your first urges to become organized are
a great place because when you have the
2/3 in your in your backyard or in
garage and suddenly something seems
viable and you're writing code or you're
put together a small object which
suddenly a shop wants your your in your
most primitive creative stage it's not
beautiful and romantic and jean-jacques
rousseau all around it there are
thorough
it's really your first urge when you
when you start going places slowly and
you start realizing that people are
interested or there's more volume or
expansion possible that's when you start
looking around say oops I need more
people but very soon after and you might
have eight or you might have twelve and
then suddenly you say oops now wait a
second this we're going to go we're
going to become bigger I need to get
organized I think this is probably the
single riskiest point because it doesn't
seem like such a big assumption you
might ask someone who's supposedly knows
or you spend some time on the web
looking at literature of organization
and then suddenly you're stuck in a
world which starts ascribing and
prescribing and describing how you
should be doing things and I think that
that is the original sin let's say both
organizations and so I would say
resisting the rationale that is being
handed down to you that you need to get
organized I think is is much more
valuable than it sounds and people look
at the inside but wait a second I don't
have the diss and I don't have a
software that does that if I don't give
my parallel to that I'll never know when
this will be wrong and so forth and you
find that the stuff let's say the
bureaucracy that that has to be dealt
with is nothing like the creative effort
of communicating and dealing with people
and giving them freedom and so you find
that as you grow from 8 to 12 to 14
years in the States
wait a sec before we could do this but
now I'm not able to just hire somebody
or agree and contract for something I
need to know what they're doing I think
that when you start asking why do you
need to know oh because if I don't know
I can't I'm following the months like
but I don't really understand what
they're doing I don't know where they
really come in I don't know if they're
working harder or less than someone else
whether it should be making that and
maybe the answer to all of this is it
doesn't matter if you know this or not
if you get down to the very very few
things that really matter to you
being unorganized a parent which is not
knowing a lot of stuff becomes
completely rather I've had now in the
last two years Tim I've been dealing
with kids you know 25 year old 28 year
old 32 year olds who have I've started
businesses with one where one of the
businesses which is in Holland for
example these guys started this business
and I have some minority partners and
some equity partners decided who I have
never met I've never met a person I've
never met on skype I have a few people
who one who let a CEO a startup etc and
I have not the slightest idea what he
looks like he's taller short and having
a very generic idea of a age and so
forth and one of these people the other
day I was at set a time to talk to and
they said all that times not very
goodness said why not and all because I
live in Australia and I said what so
yeah and he said well how the hell does
I know that is when you never asked
weather and so this this whole process
is now I think one in which I would
highly recommend to people that they do
not fall into the trap of saying I need
to get organized I need to know all of
this because the essence of what people
are trying to do with their lives their
businesses and their organizations they
really don't require the amount of
information communication and structure
that you think it needs you know what
would you suggest they focus on in
instead of that I'm just and maybe the
way to frame it is besides focusing
excessively on the bureaucracy and
putting systems in place what are some
of the other most common mistakes that
people in smaller companies and I should
say also that might not those companies
may stay the same size so they may let's
just say that in a 10 person company
they're creating a great product but
they want to scale in revenues
potentially not headcount
so a either what are the most some other
common mistakes that the people in that
position make or be what should they
focus on instead of what might they
focus on instead I think there's a lot
of rationalization a lot of tricking
yourself you know because and I think
that's a very dangerous enemy that you
don't really realize because whether
you're going to grill or not and it's
doing wild setter what happens is that
there's a point where you try some of
the things that you're you're testing
out there and that you tend to insist
very much either on an impulse on an
intuition or an early result and and you
say this is this is going to work
because that's where again the
difference between perseverance and self
trickery is is very fragile is very
delicate and so I would say that testing
impartially
and finding a way to test and partially
whether what you're doing is is really
worth what you're doing the way you're
doing it it's at etcetera I think it's a
very difficult people sometimes take a
heck of a long time to dupes and then
sometimes the business is there the
money is there etcetera but essentially
there there was nothing really of
substance there and it might take you
years and years of spinning your wheels
to realize it and sometimes when
something does not go through in the end
you start remembering those small
comments or those people who who were
naysayers all along who you were just
pushing out of the way in order to do
what you had to do because you knew was
right so I had to this whole process of
really poking of what you're doing
the product or the entity or the time
you're taking is it is a disheartening
process most of the time because very
few things really are are feasible and
most of things will run for a while and
I think that is you could poke at that
early on and be excessively transparent
and humble about whether that that
exists really
as an opportunity that be the by far the
most valuable thing you could do which
is which of your books would you suggest
say that small organization
entrepreneurs start with and which books
besides your own have you gifted the
most other people you know the the one
that you mentioned this 7-day weaken is
in a bit of place too as with with many
other books is it is a good place to go
around also inside your own head and to
look for some insights you know again
when I when I when I wrote the book
originally in and Brazil was was still
relatively closed elite environment for
business people and cetera so obviously
because the book had sold a good
quantity most people had read and I was
kept giving you know autographs to taxi
drivers and it was a very very very
small microcosm I was living in but I
remember the second occasion it has
happened to me which was being stopped
on the street and somebody saying you
know when I read your book and it
changed my life and they would go off
and quote somebody else's book in time
so when this happened the second time I
said [ __ ] this is this is not about me
at all you know this is so let me stop
right here because of course at that
point there was all kinds of campaigns
for me to run for mayor and for
president and become Brazil's Trump you
know because this is it people get lost
along the way and they start believing
in their own [ __ ] you know and and
the interesting thing here was about
going back to the issue of the book was
it it's when you when you come across an
insight which was already yours and you
see it in writing that's when you say
this book changed my life you know but
really insights where you go there you
said geez I never thought of that and
there is some of that it has to add to
something that you believe in or that
jives with your moment and so forth so I
think that putting too much weight and
too much importance on something that
you got out of somewhere not inside
doesn't remind us that this intuition in
this since I was growing inside you
already we're just waiting for some
clarification of it but that kind of
answers the second bit which is I
thought for for several years at the
Sloan School at MIT and I had a group of
MBAs and Sloan's a very fun group and I
used to go there in the Fall Quarter and
and and I tell them but this is what you
have to read to understand business and
organizations and so far time and I'm
obliged to make this available on the
MIT side anyways and then the books that
were there were Marco Polo's travel one
book of Kafka parable a huge book on
synchronicity and so far and so these
these kinds of books and tasks I think
is extraordinary and these kind of books
I think give you an enormous insight
into the people who are doing things or
why they're doing things rather than the
whole set of how tools you know and when
you when you run away from the how tools
into the issue of how you get to real
wisdom you've been at this for a long
time we've been in this agriculture area
and then we were in the industrial area
and then we were in the Information Age
and we were in the knowledge age but we
don't get any closer to the age of
wisdom and something is terribly wrong
for a population then the humanities
been around for so long and doesn't get
closer to wisdom you know we think about
organizations and you I asked you to
show me one Democratic organization or
business environment in the world or to
find one wise company of the companies
that are these are all almost impossible
to find so answering your question I
would say that the books that stop to
think about why the heck do we do the
things that we do which are in Kashgar
and
Freud our young learn to roll I think
that those will answer that business
world much closer than people think when
they say okay that's all very good and
well but that's all philosophy and
that's all airy-fairy and touchy-feely
but I I need to get down to answer this
how come which people how interpret this
process I think is much much stronger
from a philosophical point of what what
makes you want to get up in the morning
and how you let the other people around
you do what they want to do how they
want to do it and get out of their way
and then that is a philosophical issue
that I think would solve a lot more
issues if people went from that filter
onwards you know definitely and give any
particular books or writing of Kafka
that that come to mind that you would
recommend yeah there's there's one that
one that I used always there which was
which is wonderful it it's a collection
of parables there's only one and there's
a set of terms but one of them is
special interest is called before the
law and before the laws only three pages
long and I used I used to sit on a cup
of this teacher's desk there in
Cambridge and read this to the to the
kids you know the NBA kids and this was
really interesting because I really felt
like I'm reading to my small kids and I
said let me read this to you but the
fact is there's only two half inches
long but it just it just doesn't story
of a guy who sits in front of the door
which is open there's this big guy who
is guarding the door and he's a Cossack
and his goons be fur coats and he's
enormous and he's scary and the guy asks
and whether he can go in he says sure
you can go in the doors open it but
don't forget the further on there's
another door with a guy who's scared of
the night and there's another door
interpret and in the guy says what was
that I think I think I'll just wait a
bit here and this goes on and on until
those guys getting older and older and
older and then finally when he's about
to die he's lying there on the floor and
then the guy the guard
bend down and he says and he asks the
guard and he said now that I'm about to
die I have no more forces to go through
anyway what is beyond that or what's
going to happen the guard says well this
door was only for you since you are now
going to die I'm going to close it and
it's a wonderful wonderful exercise in
realizing that each to these doors that
you did not go through we're only for
you and everything that we're comparing
ourselves to all the time and the size
of our businesses and the help of the
dist and the wealth of that and how good
our family is and how good our life is
where is happiness whereas with them
etcetera it already answered this one
issue that this store is there only for
you but if you don't press it it'll
close when you die you know now i-i've
been struck with how much I was a
nonfiction purist for a really really
long time and was fortunate to have a
few people intervene and the amount that
I've taken from books like dune or Zorba
the Greek and since they're told in a
narrative form have actually stuck
compared to say the dryer in some cases
nonfiction has just been extremely
eye-opening and liberating for me I want
to ask about our this is really a
question from a fan so Philippe Boyd I
don't how to pronounce his name but this
is this is a part of his question so he
moons is referring to you he once said
he made a big fire in his backyard and
burned every article book interview
everything he had done as a symbol to
not look back has this been done again
and how is his relationship to the past
so could you elaborate on this I don't
know if it's accurate or not
but if if you could comment on that I'd
love to hear your thoughts yeah that was
when I turned 50 so I'm 67 now so when I
turned 50 I looked at my library I
looked around me and so forth and I said
[ __ ] there's a lot of stuff on me here
you know I have the mic books and all
these languages 38 languages I have a
thousand articles at DVDs I have CDs
I have even you know of course the video
cuz my I don't know I would play that
but I had it and and said there's
something wrong with this stuff you know
one em I don't need it anymore for my
ego I think umm I'm all set or I need to
figure it out with my favorites but not
here and - I have these five kids you
know I'm going to run around and
suddenly they're going to find that I'm
larger than life and people are going to
say well are you going to follow your
friend are you going to run your dad's
company organ and I said that's a
terrible imposition to make on that you
know and so I thought there were two
things holding me back one of them was
if I remember that I did this and I did
that and I have this and I have that
award and I have that I have a very
wrong sense of very superficial sense of
Who I am so I thought that if I get rid
of all this stuff I'm also a lighter for
the the trip that's in front of me and
that I can look at things from scratch
and say let's forget all that said what
would I do now and how do I kind of zero
based my life from here on and - I
didn't want these kids to be burdened by
the idea that your dad this your dad
that so what we did was we just start a
bonfire in the backyard and it took us
about five or six hours to burn
everything really just burned a hundred
percent and so just like you're asking
this is in Sao Paulo or where were you
this yeah I live up in the mountains
just wondering what your neighbors
thought okay yeah have a I didn't call
the the the firemen thing so we just
spent hours burning all this I mean it
takes a hell along and I thought it did
and and VHS tapes don't burn very well
and black smoke so we did hours of this
and so the it's now been seven years
since there is no shred of anything of
mine in the house anywhere in that
respect and the good part about it is my
wife kid they really don't have the
slightest idea what I do and and if you
ask them someone might say I'm a writer
somebody I don't do very much
I've never taken them to a company I've
never told them that one day this could
be yours
and so they it's never entered their
mind they they know that we have money
because they can look around but they've
also learned from the very beginning
that they've gone to public school with
kids who have nothing whatsoever all
along they go to the house so these kids
were very malleable and they've just
learned to accept that there's luck
there's luck when losing but here you're
born in a family that has money there's
other things that are talent and the kid
plays soccer ten times better than you
and if they found that there are other
variations but the one of your father's
this or that that one they they've never
caught up on and so that's the whole
rationale now back then I'm very happy I
did it now I don't need to every seven
years do anything because of course
nothing else comes in anything I get we
we throw up as it comes in anything that
has my name or is about me or is from
the inside of reaches we don't keep it
and that way it keeps relatively clean
I'm going to come back to the parable
and the door and the doors being yours
and yours alone and this trap that some
people fall into in terms of comparison
keeping up with the Joneses and justice
context for people I live in Silicon
Valley for those who don't know and
regularly interact with people who might
have networks of hundreds of millions of
dollars who are miserable because the
other person with hundreds of millions
or maybe billions has a larger jet than
they do or something like that and I'm
looking at areas else looking at yacht
right yachts or fill on the blanket
pissing contest and I'm looking at the
notes that I made it must have been in
2003 in the seven-day weekend so we have
let's give you a couple of samples 168
fine talent that opportunity not job
description then talent 71 the reason
for work 104 max personal wealth is 12
million that's what I'm going to dig
into in a second 123 no more than six
months
business plan or or six-month plans
versus long-term plans and I have dozens
of these but what I wanted to do is turn
to 104 because that I'd love to read a
small piece of and then just hear you
perhaps elaborate on it and perhaps your
thoughts have changed somewhat to here's
Jeff I doubt whether I actually wrote it
myself or not writing that much exactly
so um this is the paperback this is on
104 I have a theory about wealth my
friends just sigh when they hear this my
theory is that the maximum personal
wealth is twelve million dollars and
I've done some calculations with
economists to bear out this Kabbalistic
and admittedly provocative number not a
cent over twelve million after that all
millionaires are the same and then I'm
going to jump down I'm skipping a few
paragraphs but you call this the da
Vinci constraint and then the example is
a neighbor a neighbor of mine in San
Paulo built a house that reminds me of a
South American dictators compound he may
have spent his entire allotment of
twelve billion on this house but now his
problem is Leonardo who points out that
a human cannot possibly feel at ease in
such a disproportionate house certainly
my neighbor can live there open it to
photographers from design magazines and
be admired from afar but in winter he'll
huddle in the tiny TV room on the second
floor withdrawing from the cavernous
rooms to seek a more human scale and
then I'm going to bump down another two
paragraphs and I really like this lion a
lot which is collecting money is like
amassing any other item by definition no
collector can ever be happy
so as I'd love to just hear your
thoughts on this and if they've changed
at all because this is something that
the temptation this is comparison and
gross would sake of growth more I need
more and more and more that leaves a lot
of people to be very miserable could you
could you just elaborate on on this
thinking I think nowadays when you and
this is what this is about 15 years old
or something a little bit less yeah
I think in these in this last decade and
a half let I think that the number of
people who have come to realize or to
accept intellectual concept that money
is doesn't buy happiness and
growing for girls sake and comparing
yourself to everyone else and badly and
I think a lot of people accepted this as
a thought and then something in the back
of their mind says yeah but you know if
I had 12 or 20 or 15 million dollars
everything would be a lot easier and
it's only these guys who really have the
money who keep bullshitting about how
money is not important this is it right
this is where this is how it comes down
with after so much so much time thinking
about this you know it basically we're
in a world post 1989 let's say when the
Berlin Wall came down
we're in a world that says oh capitalism
has won so there's no such thing anymore
as Soviets and communists and so forth
this this stuff we've now proved the
world has proven that money is the real
Kingdom the world is a monarchy and the
king is money and of course guys who do
this better than other people have now
taken this to new proportions which is
natural it's just doing more and more
and more and more of the same so if I my
house were big enough to to huddle to
300 people and these were some of the
people from around your house let's say
and some of the most some of the
wealthiest people in the world I were to
invite them all for dinner and they were
to wake that I would have at my dinner
the wealth equivalent to half the
population of the world so I could have
in that that dinner people who have more
money than three or three and a half
billion people around the world now that
is money as king rational taken to its
most logical extent and and I started
asking myself and it has person and a
TED talk and it was the line that got
the most reactions from people for time
which was if you're giving back it's
because you've taken too much and and
people are you know I have to give back
that when you think about this and you
say you know one of your is not your
neighbor reason Seattle but let's say
Bill Gates or Warren Buffett Warren
Buffett says boy
I've been so good at this stuff you know
that I'm now made according to this
calculation few years ago I am now made
thirty billion dollars more than I need
okay so what am I going to do this let
me give it to people who really need it
so forthwith he gave it to Bill Gates
right right this was though this was a
full rationale and so there's something
wrong with people who have all have
excess money of course because you're
saying let's find someone who's already
traveling around Africa and meeting
tribes and trying to give money to AIDS
and so forth but the fact is that once
you start accumulating you're caught in
this collection mode which is you'll
always find a reason for thinking you
need more of that but it is taking away
from something it's taking away from
your kids or it's taking away from
sitting in the backyard and reading
another book or it's taking from
somewhere there's no such thing as I
will work harder for a time and then I
will have the money and then we'll and
then everything will be all right
because that moment never arrived but I
think people realize that
evermore they just people in general of
course feel that there is a level of
comfort that in your mind about your
worries about the future and the monies
and the mortgages and so forth that whoa
boy if you could have at least that bit
you'd be ok this 12 million almost
parable rationale was to say look let's
put at least an upper limit on this at a
point where and to have a house here an
apartment there and something on the
beach and something in the model in
heaven and do anything you want and go
to long vacations in Paris that was at
that time there you have to bring up to
date but it was so many dollars did
everything there was nothing you could
not do it coming from then on this was
an issue of ego vanity or obsession it
was something else it no longer had
anything to do with money on the lower
end see all these guys were doing work
on finding happiness levels and
serotonin levels and what it takes to be
minimally happy but people are always
looking in India at the people who are
untouchable and so forth and finding
levels of happiness that are high and so
I think people can accept the idea
intellectually but I think the feeling
inside is always okay but if I'd only
200 grand more silences then everything
would be okay and I think that that
isn't going away Tim in the sense that I
don't think Humanity is getting wiser in
souls you will rise but intellectually
was the first step which I think
humanity took and now starts to accept
every time more that there's something
dramatically wrong with zero one percent
it's not even to one percent but zero
one percent having such tremendous well
and this whole amassing wealth because
the wealth is going to the smarter guys
and the smarter guys are smarter guys
we're able to siphon money away from
everything else into their own pocket
come on it's a pretty dismal situation
and you come to think about it today you
think about reading and thinking about
the past a little bit Tim you think
about the robber barons like Rockefeller
and Carnegie and Vanderbilt
these guys were all monopoly players you
know these are guys for setting up
Trust's and almost everything that they
did at the time would be illegal today
now these parodies robber barons are
people that we somehow or other are very
impressed with nobody loves to be today
called to dinner by one of these robber
barons but is there a dramatic
difference today Tim when you think
about it in the biggest corporations in
the world and these people many people
who started writing code and doing
wonderful things and so far we turn now
all about monopolies and Trust's and
suddenly the guy like Trump says come to
Washington and play with me and
everybody says where's my play and I'm
ready to play there's something wrong
with this whole process because money
keeps calling money and it makes very
very disappointing people out of the
ones who've been seeking money as a big
issue money power and so forth and
you've seen it in all the films you read
it and all the books you've seen it with
people you know it does
and well but it doesn't stop any of
these people giving up other things in
favor of that which in a money world a
number and a king oriented money world
people seek and that's the bit that I
think most people are found to be silly
but they're still chasing somehow that
was a whole bit about determine adults
how do you use the question what for
when you when you do the three wise in a
row and so far as you end up with
process questions and and they're
they're very good for removing obstacles
and things that that are silly that you
do or that you're involved in doing but
it still doesn't answer the question
that has to do with wisdom and that one
is one hell for am I doing this and
that's a very very tough one because you
could eventually even answer the three
wise up for a process or for a way of
doing things and you can fix that by
asking the three wise and robot when you
when you answer you try to answer in
your marriage with your kids in the
place where you would work at the chorus
you go toward the church that you're 10
when you start trying to answer what I'm
doing this for then I think you're
you're getting to the to the real gist
of things but you're also getting into
real trouble because that those are the
really difficult ones to ask there's
there's really all of us have only one
question in the world in our lifetime
and one kid of mine asked me that means
three the other one is four and one
we're sitting in two cozy ministry and
he said that why do we exist there's
nothing else to act and there's nothing
there's no other question to ask for the
rest of your life you will never answer
it and so far and this issue what for am
I doing this why am i waking up in the
morning I go do this and why am i doing
a what what am i doing a podcast for
what good is this going to do and going
further because you'll say oh because
you know I want to help people and I
want all these
people to make their lives better and
yeah okay but what for
oh you know so that the humanity will be
better what for Oh what for because
essentially I cannot live with the idea
that I'm not making the world slightly
better than it was when I was born
even though have chances are and
statistics tells it's not the case at
all that but for me to feel that way I
need to go to the so I need to do the
podcast I need to write a book I need to
speaker conferencing to do all this but
it's not because I hope that people now
driving the car they'll suddenly stop
and get out and skip and jump to the
house and say I found new ways to do
everything in my life and everything
will be better from now but it's about
my feeling that I'm being useless and so
this whole what four issue is is used
for that as a key to try and answer
really why you do things to do what
people listening you're very well-spoken
guys so they might look at your track
record look at the accolades listen do
you speak and imagine that you've always
been confident always known what to do
could you share any particular dark
difficult times or time that comes to
mind and how you found your way out of
that on several occasions I've been lit
a close to the brink of of things not
working to a point of undoing Gary so a
few years after I started was the first
time I ran into we ran into such
financial difficulties I remember
specifically driving to the plant and
thinking what it would it would take
what it would mean is people have to
talk to to to take a company into
receivership with her or the company was
going broke and what would I do and that
was to me the the closest I ever got to
the end let's say because I was only
right or not 21 22 and suddenly
everything I tried to do was complete
wrong or was working and we came close
to the brink at that point and so what I
found I think in in that and some some
moments later I've never never come to
that same financial situation anymore
exactly but I'd come to that situation
looking at mares looking at house
raising kids looking at the opportunity
to have a much richer life and finding
myself stuck in the own traps that I'd
said for myself of doing things that I
still had to do because I said I was
going to do them and not trying to and
so this whole process I think there are
many dark moments in which for in front
of but a family or business or a wife or
four choices 14 roads we're looking back
I realized either that it wasn't as dark
as I thought it was and I was scaring
myself into things or two that I was
luckily I got through that that bend in
the road at terror so the answer is
first of all no there's it's far from
easy even though I've been terribly
lucky a lot and so if you say let me
tell me the story of the ten companies
that you started that went bust that's
easy because there's more than that the
the amount of people that you've put
together to do something that became
nothing the kind of hopes you had for
things that you were going to do that
went nowhere you know and and I've
written plays I put on plays and then
spent a year in the theater with
learning all about a drama and putting
place together and so far and I've been
lucky enough that most of the stuff kind
of wanders off or is reasonably
acceptable so that I can move on and I
think that the the real fears are always
when you you know if somebody calls you
and says oh you're example this the two
three weeks ago somebody called me and
my older kid was
morning and he says I'm calling you from
the hospital we have to operate on your
son you know things like that where your
whole life just kind of falls apart
beneath you you go and do what needs to
be done but you realize how fragile it
is to think that you're successful and
you have these big houses and you have
all these people working for you and so
confront but this stuff is all very very
delicate and very fragile so I think
there's a lot of dark moments in which
you realize well what little it takes
for you to kind of lose everything that
you were standing on you know are there
any let's say philosophies were
principles that you rely on to handle
those situations when you're reminded of
how fragile things are or uncertainty
strikes or fortune blows in the
direction that first things seemingly
off off balance yeah I have a I have a
kind of a and unnerving and unwavering
belief that we're very very
insignificant have really no idea what's
going on we're not we're not given it's
not given to us to understand anything
it's really important you know anything
that you say is really really
fundamental in life we know nothing
about we know nothing about love we know
nothing about that we know no the all of
the really important things we don't
know if you take a go to doctor and you
go for a second opinion at certificate
Center you will always realize that the
first question the first wire mind we
have this or you're just because your
nerve on this to death the second one
etcetera but the third why to any doctor
is that we don't know right everything
is that we don't know anything is really
important we don't know and so my
feeling is that because of this this
insignificance which is let's say paired
with the fact that we're terribly
important to ourselves and we're almost
100% of our importance to ourselves
we're also insignificant in the other
regard and we notice that when when
somebody passes away or when we remember
something to forgotten entirely that
this stuff is all becomes dust very
quickly and so my feeling when when
things are darker going badly or is that
it doesn't seem reasonable to me it
never seemed reasonable to me for things
to go completely our and so I'm actually
that I'm sorry that is to go completely
one re I mean going completely wrong or
going completely right a South you know
got it and that lacks a my feeling there
Tim is that you know if you're if you're
really not spending most of your time
tricking people into things and finding
ways on the side to make things work or
to make money and you're not you're
doing your basic humanity is basic in
place my feeling is that you can all
right you'll be all right and I think
that's what carries me through in the
end now it's not religious it's not
structured in any form but it's just
kind of feeling that you don't have to
do all that much just to plot along
without without being and say it is not
even naive you know so the whole
rationale of every time we have these
small choices the whole day long and by
week and month and years as we don't buy
it's very easy to differentiate between
that which is a little bit less
self-serving and that which is which is
only for your own good and if you make
enough of these choices are one I think
that it is dark moments with these
moments of enormous risk it's kind of
like a destiny or a balance that is in
place and that takes care of you somehow
you know mm-hmm it's a lot well a
semi-related note is there any
particular challenge or goal that you're
facing right now you could choose any
personal or professional that you could
describe and how you're how you're
tackling it how you're going about it
the other day I told my wife about it
I think I said this is a talk or
something that that I'm facing an empty
bucket list you know
and my empty bucket list is all about
saying this that you know my my family
is all everyone in my family had
melanoma had a form a very drastic
cancer which is very quick and and I'm
about 15 20 years ago I was already
scanned and then they told me to timer
is that at a hundred percent chance of
melanoma and cancer and I've actually
had it two three times and then in the
meantime but if you if you watch out for
of course you can be quick and remove it
and I just had surgery again about three
or four months ago found a new one and
if there's nothing to it really you
identify you know what it looks like you
go there you have removed and off you go
but I kept thinking you know sitting in
front of my my oncologist my cancer
doctor looking at me and saying well
Ricarda this time I went you didn't see
it it was something in your back and you
have three months left or six months and
we just happened to to my parents and
two people to others before them and I
kept thinking geez I don't want to be in
that situation where suddenly now I have
to go to ball games with the kids and
nice to travel to places I haven't been
and after write that play which I never
wrote and said that's crazy so let's do
something else and that's when I started
with my why should I was like the name I
gave but on Mondays and Thursdays I have
what I call terminal days and terminal
days are the two days a week in which my
schedules always completely clear I have
nothing and I do on those days what I
would have done had I heard this
conversation from my oncologist and so
I've been doing this for quite a while
and so my my weekends are with the kids
and family so forth and Mondays and
Thursdays I only do what it is I would
do if I had just recently learned that I
had a terminal disease omission sounds
dark but it is really because it's just
all about the freedom that you just
gained and these days that you've just
gotten back to do whatever you want to
do the way you do it and trying to
answer yourself what you really want to
do because in the beginning you have
this long list of things you would do if
you had the free time but it's not not
really true so I'd read all these books
which are sitting there and I had read
I'd listen to all this music which I had
but you did this for an hour two or
three but then it gets old as well and
there's a reason why you didn't do
enough of it before but it sounds like
you'll be able to do this for hours on
end but you won't and so if you're
healthy and you're in good shape and so
forth then you have your entire day
ahead of you and nothing to do you start
answering very very interesting
questions about what what you really
want and what really moves so it's still
going back to answer your question the
fact is that I've I'm not left with
goals and I'm left with all set of
wonderful processes that I love and I'd
love to do again and again but I no
longer need or want to do something that
I can measure you know the metrics I
think have gone away this this process
of doing what I want with the people I
love that I'm on that's entirely a
process on its own it's a goal on its
own and so there's no longer I have no
wishes for things that I could buy with
money you know my kids and my wife are
constantly frustrated by the fact that
there's nothing that they can buy me you
know because it's it's gotten to that
point where I don't I don't need it I
don't want it or it doesn't doesn't take
on my fancy and so forth so I'm not left
with metrics saying I'd love to have
another this sort the money I've been
doing math now I think Tim on my
personal finances for 30-something years
or more for years on the same rationale
which is how much do I need to have
enable to lead the life that I do in and
Swiss bankers used to say that you need
to have 20 times more than you spend per
year and it kind of as a rule of thumb
that's not bad
you know because that says you need
about a 5% return on monies you have so
if your lifestyle cost you and you say
three $5,000 a month to live minimally
the way I want at $60
and so you need assets and the value of
a million to house plus money whatever
so because I've been always starting
from what it is that I need
minimally to have fun and to do the many
fun things that you can do with money I
just multiply that by 20 if it if it's
over 20 I don't worry anymore and I
thankfully haven't worked for a while
but if I looked at the opportunity boy
if I did this and I put these two
companies together and that I would have
something else if it's going to take
away one of my Mondays or Thursdays or
going to take a look one of the times or
many other things I can pick up my kids
from school Saturn it's certainly a bad
deal no matter how much money or what
what metric it is you know definitely
well I mean the non-renewable resource
being that time and I'd love to hear
some details because I'm grappling with
some of these issues and structuring
structure was too formal a word but I
had a very good 2016 and I think it was
in part because I had so much slack in
the system to do deep work and to enjoy
and savor certain things and 2017
because of the book launched a few
months ago or six weeks ago has just
come crashing in with a lot of in bounds
as most of which is noise so I'm
thinking a lot about this what are some
of the processes that you love and could
you walk us through maybe a Monday or
Thursday that comes to mind and what
that what that looks like yeah and going
from back to front I've been you know
writing a book in my head now for last
two three years and I'm just scared of
putting it out there because you are
then caught in a vortex of your own
making you know and right you get a
publisher and then you kind of you kind
of sell them the idea that you're you'll
be there and they're kind of saying I'm
going to do this but if I need you for
the Today Show you're going to be there
right
and and you're kind of yeah I'll try and
so what what the fact is that you didn't
really want you never really want to
take on the whole weight of proving
yourself doing your thing and and
satisfying all the co-sponsors of your
effort right and so there's the book
launches right and there's no end of
course it doesn't end that quickly
because you treat yourself into thinking
of this is six months and then it'll be
okay but we know it's not because I just
said for example I got yesterday I just
got my two copies of the Chinese edition
of my book of 1993 so it takes a little
bit that's happened right so you know I
got the the Czech Republic additional
for the seven-day weekend about a month
ago so this stuff just takes on a life
of its own and then every time a request
comes for your time you you stutter you
know you say well you know I don't
really want to take this slide and go to
splinters but on the other hand you know
I kind of have a responsibility to do
that
and it's a little bit like the little
prince you know the French book by signs
to prepare sentence disability which
said that you are responsible for
everything that you captivate you know
and so you kind of feel you know that or
why did I write the book on first place
if I wrote in first minute that means
that I should go to this syndicated
radio show because that'll sell more
books and more people will be happy and
I'm I'll feel better on or not and
you're caught with metrics because
somebody will say so Tim Remy people
listen to your uncle a million or this
and I'm number 13 or number 11 and I'm
there six and people have caught you up
in their vortex of metrics as well until
something happens you retire you die and
so forth then it goes away because
you're a non contender from there on and
then it's perfectly alright and then you
have to think who the hell is going to
number twenty years from now or four
years from now and and so so you're left
with the issue of what am I doing this
for so my answer to all of this because
if you take this to its ultimate
consequence you could easily be in
situation where you say I do nothing
anymore because nothing is worth it
because nothing will reply to the issue
of metrics nothing will satisfy me
enough nothing is really worth it if we
are these useless specks of dust on the
the universe and so I don't I don't take
it to that pressure now because we are a
hundred percent of ourselves in terms of
importance at the same time and so you
can be worried about the state of
nations and poverty and immigration
policies but if there's a speck of dust
in your eye you're going to spend the
next hour and a half only dealing with
that there's nothing else of any
importance in the world while there's a
speck in your eye and your eyes watery
and so what a minute but this is that on
Mondays and Thursdays like that I
stopped the day I wake up and one of the
first things I do is his lounge in bed
meaning I haven't had an alarm clock I
think for for fifteen or twenty years
but I I say I'm I will not get out of
bed of course that doesn't last very
long but the feeling is good and then
I'm with the kids and so forth and and
suddenly they get into the vent and
they're not something everything is
quiet in one second and and then I start
asking myself so what I wanted to do I
could read the paper but I don't really
want to read the paper in the news is
this and that I could read that book but
now I'm halfway there I couldn't and
you're stuck I think many times with the
issue that you we keep ourselves so busy
and we have all of these distractions
and attractions and things going at such
a rate that when you actually turn off
all the noise and say which of this is I
really want to do you you have much more
trouble than you thought you did and so
when we put that book out there or as
you did and you have requests and you
have opportunities you really just kind
of measure the opportunities of what to
do
to each other so you know in that in
that sense it's a bit like Kafka again
you know back that doors open just for
you but you say you know with is it
better to go talk to these guys in
Denver or to do this thing in London you
know but the real question was what the
hell for am i doing either of these and
I think you'll end up with the with the
reply that the thing that you can look
back on you say that was a good one two
hours three hours of my life because I
either shared something I learned
something my I felt good
these are all wonderful responses I you
know if you went to the baseball game
you're not losing two hours of your life
that's a wonderful way to spend those
two hours issue of baseball on or not
and so um it's not about nothingness or
undoing yourself or consider yourself
worthless and therefore it's not worth
or anything and but it is especially
about not comparing the opportunities
with each other and rather compare them
what would I do if I had the whole day
off the best feeling I have in my in my
time is never the Monday and Thursday
which I do love where when I get at em
in bed thank you today I have nothing to
do it is on that Tuesday or on that
Friday when I have something set a
conference call or as is it or something
and that gets canceled that's my my most
wonderful poem with is always when I
have to do is somebody cancelled it you
know the enormous sense of relief no
matter how important it was are which I
was looking forward to it said when
somebody cancels something I feel elated
you know and so I think that kind of
answers a bit as well no no it does in I
mean I'd love to uncover some of the
some of the quirks hide somebody asked
me a question a few days ago that I
thought was a good question we'll find
out it may be it may fall flat but he
asked me water what are some absurd
things that you like doing or love doing
what are some absurd things that you
love doing does anything come to mind
for you when I ask that question
I have have all these bold online habits
one of them comes from Winston Churchill
which is to sit in the bathtub with a
lit cigar you know I'm sure water it'll
pass a lot of people's tests of
absurdity but so sometimes I'll say you
know now I will do nothing and I will
sit in a bathtub for an hour and a half
with it was a very long cigar and think
like Winston Churchill and House
remember this especially well because
Churchill was a guy who was even in
power and to an extent this happened to
FDR as well when he had his polio thing
in Florida but Winston Churchill would
go off a bit before Christmas and take a
shift to Egypt where he would go to it
the same Winter Palace Hotel Jane look
sir and he would spend 65 days there
while he was running the country and so
I think we give ourselves an enormous
amount of importance into our time and I
think doing absurd things up related to
wasting time I think are a wonderful way
to remind ourselves that were neither
that important or that messer or not
that much happens when you do absurd
things with your time agentic purposely
looking like you're wasting it I think
is in an absurdly wonderful thing to do
do you know people looking from the
outside in many people be very impressed
with your ability to experiment and to
test and to have failures but also have
these successes and homeruns do you
think about risk differently than other
people or how do you think about risk I
think that that word is a scary word to
a lot of people and they don't really
define it for themselves and so they
don't try but I just love to hear your
thoughts on risk or perceiving risk how
you think about it when you when you try
and deconstruct with
I'd say they're there there's an
objective metric associated with risk so
I'm going to start this business I'm
going to take 32 percent of my savings
and I lose it all so that's a kind of
metric that I think is less scary
because you know that it's 32 percent
you know that if you lose it you're
going to it's going to be trouble for
some time and then some restrictions etc
but it is an outside metric which you
are willing to accept if you say I'm
going to take a plane and I know that
the statistical risk is zero comma zero
zero four or this or that or a peak
coming late and then 100 times smaller
of the plane falling and I'll I'll take
that risk a bit I think scares people
very little even though they bring it up
I think people use it very much as an
excuse because the other risk factor is
how will I look to myself to my spouse
to my kids to my former business
partners to my room now how I look if I
flat fall flat on my face and I think
that this element of risk is the one
that doesn't bother me almost at all
because I think it is so ephemeral you
know you get a bad press or you get a
bad opinion from neighbors or your wife
is dismayed that you actually did this I
think all this goes away very easily and
relatively quickly it might take you
months of years but all this goes away
and it's not to say that it's worth
doing because if you do succeed then you
will show them all your other face or
you'll be happier you'll be gratified
yourself even because we know that a lot
of these apparent successes and apparent
things that we call home runs
they're also temporary right in that
sense that you write to do something and
the last mile of everything you do is
probably what's going to count this is
also an ironic turn on life which is you
go there and you spend twenty thirty
years today this day today today
had one of our biggest billionaires in
Brazil fall into jail it was in New York
over the weekend and he was arrested and
he's involved in a corruption charge and
he was the seventh richest man in the
world who's by far
Brazil's richest burst his twenty thirty
years of an earning successes and one
success on top of the other were all
wonderful and he obviously had the
genius for business otherwise he
wouldn't have gotten where he got and he
has his dark side as well and so fight
so he got to this point I don't know in
person I've never met but he got to this
point where he's this billionaire and he
had this enormous projects and he was
doing wonderful things and he had on the
side he had hobbies and restaurants and
yachts and doing things for poor people
and no no no no not now he's in jail I
don't know for how long maybe maybe even
not that long but the fact is that he
has these his hair products companies I
was very proud of his hair and you know
another guy who who has similar hair and
he in jail the first thing they did was
to shave him bald so you see you know it
you know whatever I meant to say was
what is success for this guy you know
was it the 34 years in which he had
yachts and planes and every president
everybody would receive and lead to
wonderful things and so for nine or is
it now so tainted by this last image of
something he will never recover you know
and I'm no judgement at all I'm just
saying that when you think about this so
I think about some people who are
presidents of Brazil's and people who
are presence of the US who are there at
Pfister sits in their life is over it's
no longer success it keeps deteriorating
as they as the years go by you know you
can take someone like like Clinton who
has an extraordinary mind did a lot of
good things but this isn't made a few
enormous mistakes with cigars and
trainees that he will never recover from
and so what what is success in that
passage so I meant what I meant to say
was that your home runs and the
businesses you
the money you haven't spent it is all
very very fragile and it's probably
going to be measured with how you handle
yourself in a few very few of decisive
moments in your life and or in the end
you know the last few things you did are
terribly important compared to what you
did before and or this guy I can forget
his name
Pistorius or pistol pissed arias in
South Africa it has tremendous guy
setter until you kill your girlfriend
and suddenly that all those other
successes don't don't sit very well now
can you do your things have your
successes build up your metrics etc and
then retire and sit tight for 20-30
years enjoying etcetera probably the
feeling inside is that soul your worlds
are deteriorating in the sense that your
friends are dying the press is no longer
interested in you and you become a
has-been who still has a few things to
to nail up on the wall or remember the
you know jaded photographs of you with
someone very important you know and so I
think that the success factor and this
metric of how you measure yourself is
very very fragile and when we stick to
it we stick to something that won't be
there when we try to hold it in our
hands it has to be held a bit like a
bird you know should press it a little
bit too hard at that how do you think of
success for yourself then in place of
leaning on or depending on the ephemera
and all these things that can be taken
away so easily or destroyed so easily
how do you how do you feel at peace with
yourself or ural successful what what
how do you what lens do you use for that
I try to I try to exchange these lenses
of past and future for living in the
present which is the only very difficult
thing to do we talk about it but nobody
knows how to do it you know the change
Taylor said in a song is that the
meaning of life is to enjoy the passing
of time it during the passing time is
far the hardest thing we can ever do and
we take your thought process we are
almost constantly living in the past or
in the in the future and so success to
me is always making sure that this
passing of time is worthwhile at this
passing of time right now that I'm not
exchanging it for a hope in the future
I'm not exchanging for something I got
or had in the past and then you're
always kind of ready to survivor to
withstand through the use of this wisdom
of present time of which I'm very far
still from it but I just keep hammering
it into my own head this passing of time
if this podcast and conversation with
you was worth it because it made me
think because it was thoughtful for us
in so far that it that is success and
that can never be taken away no matter
tomorrow I don't have the money I don't
have this where things go wrong
god forbid with with people the fact is
that that one hour two hours which we
spent in the broadcast thinking about
life continues and exchanging that that
one was definitely worthwhile and
successful and that one can no longer be
taken away from you because it's not
part and when it becomes part of your
history or your past it's just building
blocks of time that were spent you know
I had an interesting situation with for
a time I was I was buying much more wine
than I should have because I was kind of
I got into the collectors mode about
25-30 years ago and so I can buying at
auctions and of course you get into this
thing where you need to have that 1969
doll otherwise and so forth until you go
crazy at auction you overpay and so
forth and and one of these days I had a
friend over and I opened one of these
wonderful ones that were extraordin
extraordinary rate for it and so forth
and this stuff can be used for vinegars
completely spot it was always completely
spot when I bought it was already worth
nothing whatsoever
and I always thought it was an
interesting collection because you you
buy all of this wine that you have all
kind of expectations from and you're
learning to say you know this has pencil
shavings in a bit of mineral glad and
some marigold flower in the taste and so
far but you know there's an enormous
amount of [ __ ] in what you're doing
and why you're doing it and so forth but
the interesting part is that once you
consume your collectible by drinking the
wine you're left
always with 20 cents of glass you know
which is and so it's just always saying
that this whole process of wine is a
good is a good comparison because one
guy told me a few khatoun what what gets
you into your your cellar and makes you
take a bottle wine which you paid $100
for is now whereas a thousand dollars
and drink this and be left with a little
bit of glass because you end up probably
not even having the courage to drink
this wine that now is so valuable
etcetera but I always answered that in
the following way if one day I look at
my cellar and I dunno and it's about
half empty or more and though it is now
about half empty and I think that every
time I pulled one of those bottles it
was because I was with friends or
because I was feeling good or this was a
great time this must have been a good
life looking at those empty holes you
know and so that's I think with
everything else if you're using that
time and you at the end of it you say
boy that was a good two hours or so this
is worth it then successes is certainly
guaranteed how did you stop the
collection of wine when you were getting
caught up in these auctions and so on
what was the pattern interrupt or the
conversation of the moment when you
decided to stop doing them I actually
remembered very well is pretty specific
I went to Thailand and and in Thailand I
met this guy who's actually Chinese but
he was in Thailand and he was
tomato farmer and he had mini Mills he
had these mini steel mills steel mills
and he was a magnet and he'd made his a
real tycoon he'd make enormous amounts
of money a senator and we were we went
to have dinner with this guy
and he was smoking all through the
dinner and I asked him you know how many
cigarettes he smokes a day or acts and
he said no I like one in bed and then I
light all the cigarettes with another
cigarette so I never did them I never
did the math on that where it can't be
very good but anyway so he would he
would eat with one hand and he would
puff for the other and at no moment did
he stop smoking and then we started
talking about he said the tea has a bit
of an obsession for things and so funny
says he collects and I said will you
collect and he said I collect Mercedes
cars so and you have a lot of these
anything you have a lot of these I have
111 warehouses oh my god Mercedes and
you said and I have the most of the
first Mercedes of 1896 which is a steam
Mercedes and I have all the Mercedes in
between and I said what do you mean so
every time there is a Mercedes that
comes out every year they come out with
let's say six models I buy one of each
and when Mercedes needed Himmler's car
and the car that Hitler went into pairs
of what I lent them the cars because I
have the Christ okay and so I was there
obviously stunned at this conversation
and although they're smoking as that
jesus what a little do I know about
interesting people are freaking people
around the world and then I at one point
I said well but so it would you just
keep on collecting since that says and
of course I have to go I have to go in a
few days
I'm going to an auction because there
are several Mercedes there the total of
12 Mercedes which I don't have and I
said to analysis buddy so all I keeps me
awake many nights said and I keep going
at it and I'm going crazy and we're
going to have these twelve more sense
and at that moment I start buying any
wine but I don't think I thought a wine
oh my god what a story we we could go
for a very long time I want to be
respectful of your time there's so many
things that I'd love to touch on like
lugar and in many other areas but tell
me what you think of this we could do a
few rapid-fire questions and then maybe
if you enjoyed this and everyone enjoys
it which I think they will we could
consider maybe doing I'll follow up at
some points I'm certainly happy to stay
on and talk about anything you'd like
but I'd I'd love to ask maybe a few
rapid-fire questions and then lead
people to what you're up to now and
where they can they can find you if that
if that sounds like a plan but I know
we've been on for recording now close to
two hours so if that works for you
because we could take that approach but
I'm certainly happy to touch on anything
that you'd like to talk about now let's
do that and you're I mostly want
rapid-fire replies as well which is not
much special no the rapid-fire questions
really just means that I have to stop
asking multi-part questions with 17
commas so your answer can be as long as
you'd like
so I will just keep my questions short
and I'm certainly not in any rush so
this number one is what books have you
reread the most yourself know very well
always go back to two books one by Carl
youngin and this whole issue of
collective unconscious which is to be a
big issue because you either are able to
touch in and touch and get involved
somehow in this collective unconscious
or you're doing things which are very
much on your own and not significant in
the sense that they're trailblazing
insiders did they're just not connected
to the world as they should be
and I never I keep I keep going back to
it's very interesting because I come
from a Jewish family even though nobody
was was religious there's a there's a
cultural romantic issue there but I only
found out actually I'm Jewish too maybe
10 years ago and
even though I have suspicious of it but
the one that I read every once I want to
pick up because it's around the house
and because my wife is a bit more
religious is the Bible that is a
wonderful set of stories philosophy
attend and I read it much like you would
read Shakespeare you know and it's
stronger because it has everything
Shakespeare has all the human traits
that you look somewhere you will find it
either in King Lear and have learned
both methods there and and the live I
was very interesting book to keep going
back to to to get a glimpse of humanity
do you have any favorite documentaries
or movies yeah my favorite documentary
is one called up are you seeing that I
have yes fantastic and and for the
people listening to this it's a guy
Michael Apted who were in 1964 decided
to follow about a dozen actually more
kids from very different backgrounds and
from in the UK and there's some in
orphanages in so I'm very well off to
try and establish how much people are
stuck to their to their context to their
social context and so when it's very
interesting because he follows them
every 7 years right so it's 7 14 21 28
and so forth until 56 which was the last
one and it's quite an extraordinary way
to look at humanity and see can people
really escape their social constraints
and their initial lay of life you know
and in general is assumption is that
they cannot end it into a great sense
that there's itself out no Tim in the
sense that it doesn't look like you can
you can strayed that far from the path
on average them yeah it's I think they
revisited them what every five years or
something like that endeavour 7 I'm
sorry that's right because it was 7 up
and then it became the 7 up series yeah
they're all multiples of 7 but it's the
same people which is extraordinary you
seeing someone who's 7 was 14 was 21 is
28 was now 50
six and their dreams and their hopes and
what they were actually able to do and
how close they in these seven year
periods how close they have stayed -
they're calling a parent calling in life
before they were born
it's an incredible situation yeah it's
this is this is the documentary series
it's come up three or three or four
times I'd never heard of it before
interviewing a number of people on the
podcast so that I was actually
introduced to the series through the
podcast as well it's wonderful and just
just on that tone to say that you know
you're you're in a country that says boy
anybody can do anything you anybody can
be anything don't let anybody stand in
your way you can be a setter but it's
not really true at all this is I think a
very interesting take on this
documentary and on the American Dream
you know even what's what's happening
today in the u.s. is a reaction to this
where the [ __ ] is my American Dream dubs
promise to me you know but the fact is
that you're promising classroom loves
kids and as a valedictorian and speaking
at conferences and egging them on at
MBAs the fact is that you cannot you
know humanity is a very very long story
and a very very long proof that in
general your chance of changing walks of
life changing class changing path from
what the context which you were started
with it's a very very rare situation
that very very rare situation makes for
wonderful books and speeches and films
but it only makes for these wonderful
for this wonderful entertainment because
it's so so rarely true now is that very
dismal and disappointing to look at and
say well you know now that you've put
this in my face now I'm not going to try
anything it's not even worth it no it's
just to remember that in the passing of
time of the station of life that was
that was created or available to you in
your context there could be and should
be a wonderful life the wonderful life
is not you
rising all the time until you're at the
top there's nothing that's particularly
interesting at the top it just seems
absolutely wonderful when you look at it
from the bottom what would you say for
instance if you were teaching again but
instead of at the MBA program at MIT you
were teaching a ninth grade class in
some economically disadvantaged area
let's just say it could be the ghetto in
Chicago could be any number of places in
the u.s. what would you teach in that
ninth or 10th grade class to help them
improve the odds of not remaining in
their current cycle and then I have you
know we obviously you you talk way too
much so we haven't had time to talk
about education which I'd love to as
well but of course I've taken let's say
the last 10 12 years I've taken all of
this effort and this risk taking what I
learned before and taking it to the
world of Education and but I spent the
first the first years of that teaching
six-year-olds in a public school and
heavily disadvantaged kids and so far so
it was fun to do what I what I tried to
do most with them was to get them to
realize the magic of the accumulated
wisdom of humankind and then poking at
this magic of what we've been able to do
and think and all this time all the rest
will take care of itself and so if I sit
there and say you can do this you can
you know find the strength within you it
is possible you can do anything you want
you can be anything you want I don't I
don't believe in that and so I kept
showing them things like I would say I
remember one day I was stepping outside
of there and said let's I'm going to
teach you the special relativity theory
of Einstein so it's like this you're
here with me in this little village
right right now you look up and I say
how long would it take you to go to the
moon
and so it is a land and rockets and all
well then promote to the next and on and
on into Neptune and rains great and then
to the edge of the universe and then
this their mind is going all over the
place of course and we're trying to
think this through together and I said
if you come to the end of the world the
end of the universe and there were a
little curve and now you've traveled for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years in your rocketship and so forth
and now according to this man mr.
Einstein you open this little curtain at
the end of the universe where would you
be
and the answer in installing the theory
and people will know this will tell you
you will be in this little village right
here while looking up into the sky and
these crazy crazy concepts which are
true and which are about us and to say
that here we are up here in the
mountains so time here moves a little
quicker than it does at beach level and
so that you have exact twins who are
born and one is on the beach one is in
the mouth by the end of 90 years when
they meet again the one in the mountain
will be older will be slightly older
this kind of stuff is to me what unlocks
the whole possibility for people to
think boy I can be anything doing each
other because they're looking at the
magical response of what life looks like
what we've learned all along to this
date and that is the key that they can
eventually use to free themselves you
see I do uh if you could have a gigantic
billboard anywhere and actually
netiquette billboards are there no
billboards in Sao Paulo I feel like
that's one of a few cities that is
perhaps made to billboards illegal but
that's that's an aside the the the
metaphorical question is if you could
have one gigantic billboard anywhere
with anything on it in other words just
getting a short message out to millions
of people what would you put on that
billboard ID right now
that's enough anything if people pay
attention to to now so many other issues
go away because I did so much of
everything we do is taken up by the past
of the future and so little of our
successes there that remembering that
you're now in a bus you're now on a
train you're now going somewhere you
don't want your now this is the stuff
that I think falls short all the time
and as some others have a lot of
restrictions on on Billboard's and it's
expensive and it takes authorizations
and so forth so that helps but some
other something other visual problems
now we have a new Trump like mayor who
is going around and covering up all of
the spray-paints of the with graffiti
artists that's the newest well I think
this is a good place to to wrap up and
give any end I'll ask you where people
can find more about you and certainly I
put on show notes as well but you have
any ask or request for my audience the
people listening any or any last parting
words that you'd like to share yeah I'd
say that you know again when I think
about why why would I sit with you and a
two-hour podcasts why would I have a few
people that I wanted to talk to and that
I'm doing this little podcast episode of
my own it's all to do with and
essentially of course it's all is it
soft was it insightful for myself and
therefore so very self-serving and very
very narrow let's say but on the other
hand my my very generic wish is always
that people will be able to take a
little something out of it which is
interesting side into something that was
already there not that we created in
this conversation but that someone based
on a little act of courage in either
giving more freedom to people who work
with them or for them or their kids or
their anything that's around and I think
that that's it's terribly gratifying to
do just these very small leaps of faith
and these very small movements in the
direction
what seems like risk and and is never
risk because it's never a metric issue
it's just getting past your own
misgivings about doing something new and
then that would be my hope that people
take this little leap of fancy or leap
of faith and finally decide to make a
change on constraints on restrictions
that they either have or that they need
to fight against or they need to remove
other people from and find that that's a
hell of a lot more liberating than it
sounds well Ricardo I really appreciate
you taking the time this was extremely
fun for me and I've known you only
through video and text up to this point
so this was a unique opportunity for me
so number one thank you for taking the
time and for those people listening I
will put links to everything that was
mentioned books and podcast and
otherwise in the show notes as per usual
you can find those at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast or 4-hour work
week compo slash podcast you can say
hello and you should too Ricardo at
Ricardo Semler and at let's lead wise on
Twitter Facebook is let's lead wise and
LinkedIn is Ricardo Semler
and until next time as always thank you
for listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday is that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and 500 Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just
for our workweek dot-com that's for our
workweek com all spelled out and just
drop in your email and you will get the
very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront is the future of
financial advice they've become
incredibly popular among my friends in
Silicon Valley and across the country
because they provide the same high end
financial advice that the best private
wealth managers deliver to ultra wealthy
but for any account size and at a
fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealthfront now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealth front is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have bloated sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so the very least go
to wealth front compote / Tim and take
their free risk assessment survey it
only takes a couple of minutes and
wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go to well press compos on tim
to get your first 15k managed for free
or just to get more details check it out
wealthfront comm forward slash tip this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
first books is now the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self-employed professionals and used
by more than 10 million people
you can send invoices track your time
and get paid fast which basically
describes the core needs of most
entrepreneurs and freelancers the
product was recently relaunched and
rebuilt from the ground up focusing on
since
and speed it's an awesome service and
many of you recommended it to me which
is how they came to be a sponsor now I
can't cover all of the many many
features but for example you can take
pictures of receipts on your phone using
FreshBooks iOS mobile app or connect
your bank account or credit card to
fresh books and watch your expenses
automatically import into your account
every day and if you have any questions
whatsoever a real live person answers in
less than three rings to help you with
all of your needs so to claim your
30-day unrestricted free trial that
means no credit card needed and see how
the all new fresh books can change your
freelancing game go to fresh ebooks.com
forward slash tim and enter tim t IM in
me how did you hear about us section
that is fresh books comm forward slash
tim and then put tim t IM in the how did
you hear about us section
[Applause]